perhaps I might start with mr. James
Murdoch you made a statement on 7th of
July in which you stated that the paper
had made statements to Parliament
without being in the full possession of
the facts and that was wrong he was
sensually admitted the Parliament had
been misled in what we have been told
can you tell us to what extent will we
mislead and when he became aware of that
and mr. chairman thank you very much
first of all I would like to say as well
just how sorry I am and how sorry we are
to particularly the victims of illegal
voicemail interceptions and to their
families it's a matter of great regret
of mine my fathers and everyone at News
Corporation and these are standards
these these actions do not live up to
the standards that our company aspires
to everywhere around the world and it is
our determination to both put things
right make sure these things don't
happen again and to be the company that
I know we have always aspired to be as
for my comments mr. chairman in my
statement which I believe was around the
closure of the news of the world
newspaper one send this is the most
humble day of my life